[Music]
the emmy awards made history last night
hope you stayed up late as the biggest
live virtual awards show during the
pandemic
jimmy kimmel hosted at the empty staples
center in los angeles he was knockout
good
more than 100 nominees were linked
remotely from 20 cities
and 10 countries around the world the
sitcom it's called shit's creek as
c-h-i-t-t also made history sweeping the
emmy comedy awards for the very first
time entertainment tonight host kevin
frazier shows how the emmys team
pulled it off you know what they say you
can't have a virus without a host
it didn't take host jimmy kimmel along
to acknowledge that the sea of
hollywood's biggest stars
featured in his opening monologue was
nothing more than tv magic
instead of a live audience we took a
page from baseball tonight and we filled
the seats
with cardboard cutouts of the nominees
hello everybody
and when the stars couldn't come to
hollywood camera feeds
socially distant statue delivery and
self-opening trophy boxes
allowed hollywood to come to them
the cast of shit's creek a sitcom about
a formerly wealthy family
who moves to a small town bought as a
gag gift was together sunday night
as the show won all seven comedy awards
for its final season
an envy first i actually think that this
sort of solidifies that we went out on a
good note
some stars appeared on stage with kim
all right sanitized for your protection
yeah now this is exciting
we can't wait five minutes others with
fellow cast members
we're ready for this year to be over
but most like zendaya were surrounded by
friends and family
the 24 year old became the youngest
winner for lead drama actress
for her role in euphoria sunday's show
had a record number of black nominees
and winners
because black stories black performances
and black lives matter and many took the
opportunity to
draw attention to social issues wearing
shirts in support of black lives matter
and brianna taylor including uzo aduba
who won for supporting actress in a
limited series for her role in mrs
america
what does it mean to you
it means everything to me as celebratory
of a night as this is kevin and we know
it to be
yes i didn't want to forget what's
happening
outside i wanted to bring a piece of
that inside
you know uzo won for playing shirley
chisholm an often overlooked
but also important political figure and
i also want to mention that it was a big
night for tyler perry
the producer actor slash media mogul um
received the governor's award
he used his speech to highlight the
power of diversity and gail you know
better than most that
there is no one with a bigger heart or
more generous than time
you're so right he had been working on
that speech all for the last couple of
days
great tribute to his mom we we talked
about it earlier kevin and said people
need to go online
but the whole night was great because
people got to celebrate with their
people that mean the most to them yeah
it was a great great great hold off a
great show they did gavin thank you